dr amesh adalja joins us now he's a
senior scholar at the johns hopkins
center for health security at the
bloomberg school of public health he is
in pittsburgh doctor good morning
good morning thanks for having me so we
know that this third shot is now
authorized for people with compromised
immune systems the question is
what about everyone else doctor does it
look like others may soon
you know be in that category where a
third booster shot may be beneficial
in the short term it's not likely that
we're going to see boosters for the
average healthy person that's fully
vaccinated to me the threshold for
needing a booster vaccine is to see
breakthrough infections landing people
in the hospital and that's just not
happening the vaccines are holding up
tremendously when it comes to preventing
serious disease hospitalization and
death so there may be a time down the
road where we need boosters but i think
it's premature to think about that for
healthy individuals at this time when we
look at part of that unvaccinated
population right now it is kids under 12
still not able to get the vaccine
just coming in this morning one of the
things i heard is that it looks like now
winter time for those that are under 12.
can you give us an update where are we
with kids and why does it seem to be
taking so long
well the clinical trials are still going
on and you have to remember a couple of
weeks ago the fda asked to expand those
trials to be able to pick up any rare
side effects anytime you give a vaccine
to someone there's a risk benefit
calculation that needs to be undertaken
and it is true that children are spared
from the severe consequences of disease
so there is a different risk calculation
when you're vaccinating a 10 year old
versus when you're vaccinating a 60 year
old and that's what we're trying to do
with these trials to understand where
that risk benefit falls and i think
parents should should realize that
children are spared from the severe
consequences of disease in general it
doesn't mean it never happens but it's
rare and i think we are plotting along
with this vaccine the faster it comes
out the better but we want to make sure
that people have confidence in this
process that it is a safe and effective
vaccine in that specific age group and
do we have a sense when that i know as
you say they are getting that all the
data that they want to find but do we
have any sense of when we may see kids
being able to get this
likely late fall early winter for that
age group of five to 11 and then even
longer for children under the age of
five
doctor what what do you think this you
talk about fall in winter last year what
what is this fall and winter going to
look like because i think in may in june
of this year a lot of people thought we
were
getting to be done with the pandemic now
it seems that's not the case
our fall and winter are really going to
be dictated by how many people get
vaccinated how many people get infected
during this wave of the delta variant we
know that coronaviruses accelerate their
transmission when it gets colder when
it's less sunny when it's less humid
when people move indoors we know that
we're going to be contending with other
respiratory viruses so unless more
people get vaccinated unless we get a
handle on the delta variant we're still
going to get disruptions in certain
parts of the country just like we are
now
with covid19 so this is something we
really have to encourage people to take
seriously and get vaccinated the sooner
the better if we want this pandemic in
our rear-view mirror so dr new york city
became the first city to require proof
of at least one dose for certain indoor
activities we know that san francisco
will require both this is all happening
at the same time you have some governors
pushing back against mass mandates what
is your take on this
it's much much safer to do almost any
activity if you're fully vaccinated and
if you're a business owner you don't
want covet 19 spreading in your in your
organization and i do think that this
it's coming to a point where we have to
start distinguishing between the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated because
if you're fully vaccinated the virus is
going to treat you very differently then
it's going to treat someone that's not
vaccinated so other people should treat
you very differently because you're no
longer a threat so i think we're moving
towards this unless we get the
vaccination numbers higher because it's
just
very likely with the more contagious
variant spreading that you're going to
see delta variant cases impinging on
normal activities that people do
when you mention that i feel that a lot
of people who are vaccinated with the
delta variant have now started
questioning some of the things they were
doing well i was going to baseball games
and doing these things outside should i
should i be wearing a mask what is your
advice when it comes to people who are
trying to sort of figure out what should
they do and what maybe they shouldn't do
now
if you are fully vaccinated you can rest
assured that the delta variant doesn't
pose a threat to you
in the way that it would if you weren't
vaccinated meaning you're unlikely to
get serious disease hospitalization or
death the vaccines are holding up really
well there are breakthrough infections
occurring and thankfully because of the
vaccine the breakthrough infections are
really mild this is evidence of the
vaccine working so it really boils down
to your risk tolerance when you're fully
vaccinated most of these breakthrough
infections are going to be akin to the
average common cold that you get and if
you're somebody that's immunocompromised
that may be something important for you
to to try and avoid but for other people
what activity you're pursuing that risk
might be outweighed by the benefits you
get from that activity so it's al it's
all going to be risk calculation based
on individuals values and what they want
to do it's not going to be one size fits
all but the vaccine is the best way to
make the delta variant a non-issue for
you dr adalja quickly before we let you
go if i can go back to kids for a minute
we are seeing more hospitalized now and
in the beginning it seemed that kids
weren't as affected by the coronavirus
why are we seeing more children
hospitalized and affected right now
especially by the delta variant
the delta variant is looking for
unvaccinated people and it just so
happens that people under the age of 18
have a lower vaccination rate and
especially those under the age of 11 who
are not able to be vaccinated so they're
getting infected more also children are
back to their activities more they were
shielded a lot during the early parts of
the pandemic but it still remains true
even though we're seeing these
hospitalizations that that's not the
norm for a child and i think the best
way to protect children is to get more
people vaccinated including all the
adults that surround a child and for
those children above the age of 12 this
is an important decision parents should
be getting their children vaccinated
that's the best way to keep them safe dr
adelga thank you very much